[Music]
get ready to laugh because we found some
pretty hilarious
epic toy fails there is no chance any
kid would actually want to play with
these seriously nothing could have
prepared us for this last one on this
list if you're new to the things be sure
to subscribe and give this video a big
thumbs up if we made you laugh now let's
check out the 10 messed up toys no kid
would want as a present don't be a
horse's behind this Chinese toy seems
innocent enough but it looks like a
pretty blue horse with a blue mane and
wait is that a blonde tail apparently
you could pull the horse apart so you
can see this inside let's talk about why
that alone is pretty terrifying to a
child horses aren't supposed to split
down the middle and open up like that
that's not how horses work but what was
found inside is the most bizarre thing
ever that blonde tail is attached to a
severed doll head who thought this was a
good idea we have so many questions is
this a blue child eating horse if so how
did it swallowed this girl's head hole
does it have the ability to open its
jaws like a snake and where's the rest
of the dolls body for real what was the
process in making this thing was the
horse toy maker distract because he
forgot to make a tail for the horse and
then ran into a doll maker who was
agonizing over what to do with all his
extra doll heads is it possible they
came together confident that this was
the best solution to the problem this is
like a reverse Godfather situation
nesting dolls nesting dolls are a
classic toy these dolls are meant to be
a symbol of fertility and big families
they are called mother dolls in Russia
and they are the most purchased souvenir
in that country but not every one of
them can be a winner this toy designers
started out strong the first doll looks
artistic detailed and full of life but
it seems as the artist got to the last
doll he lost a bit of steam the dolls go
from having sparkling artistic facial
expressions to mischievous little dots
for eyes with lines for eyebrows that
make us think these dolls are going to
be in trouble with the law
when they grow up by the last one he's
not even trying anymore the flower
devolves from one with purple flowers
that have depth and beauty to five
little white dots that last when a doll
or a baby carrot with a face on it we
wanted to make sure this isn't the norm
so we checked into it other toy makers
took the time to meticulously paint
detail
even the smallest doll in this toy fail
however by the last doll it seems the
guy just gave up four legged duck we're
no experts on duck Anatomy but it
appears something just isn't right here
from our own experiences where we walked
through the park and looked at ducks
with our eyes we remembered a few key
things about our feathered friends they
have beaks wings a feather tail and two
webbed feet but something about this
stuffed toy duck has us shaking our
heads let's go down the duck Anatomy
checklist it's got a beak check it's got
a feather on the top of its head check
it's got wait a minute are we seeing
this right yep that's a four-legged duck
my friends the person who made this toy
needs to get outside more or at the very
least watch a nature show on TV what's
wrong with this dude maybe he lives in
the next nuclear power plant where Ducks
are mutated to have four legs you know
like the three legged fish in the
Simpsons regardless it would be pretty
irresponsible to give this toy to a
confused child we wouldn't want her to
grow up thinking Ducks have four legs we
wondered what other stuffed animals are
on the production line a one-legged
zebra or how about a three armed sloth
somebody failed geography this car has
got all the elements of the Australian
outback
it's got desert like sands eucalyptus
trees kangaroos a red desert sunset and
the word Austria written on the fender
not everyone can ace it every time this
toy designer clearly failed geography
now we will admit we had to look up the
exact location of Austria but we
definitely knew it was nowhere near the
country of Australia ready for a
geography lesson here we go
the Republic of Austria is located in
Central Europe is bordered by the Czech
Republic and Germany to the north
Hungary and Slovakia to the east
Slovenia and Italy to the south and
Switzerland to the west most of Austria
is covered by mountains alpine region
for the dozens of lakes peppered
throughout these mountains what it
doesn't have our red sandy deserts and
kangaroos Australia is way south on the
planet eight thousand eight hundred and
twenty-five miles south to be exact we
realize that this is a typo but we think
it's a hilarious one it just goes to
show that even if you fail geography at
school you can still go on to have a
mediocre career at the toy factory that
spreads boss information to children an
armless bear without a body
imagine for a moment that it's Christmas
morning you run downstairs to see
presents under the tree you run to the
teddy bear perched playfully next to a
present box and you giggle with delight
because you got the teddy bear you've
been dreaming of when you hug his little
stuffed body it feels a little strange
you feel for its puffy belly and
something doesn't feel right you decide
to investigate so you remove its cute
little sweater when you take the sweater
off you realize that it's cute little
bear arms are coming off with the
sweater then you look down in horror to
find two weird floppy long legs they go
all the way up to its neck and that's
the moment you realized you were going
to need therapy for a long time how
traumatic with this be to a young child
were they on a major time crunch at a
teddy bear factory who knew that making
teddy bears was such a high stress gig
this looks like the most bizarre
before-and-after set of pictures this
teddy bear has a serious case of armless
leg syndrome hopefully this is the only
one of its kind so creepy I am a sweet
baby let's have fun together we love the
fact that the package says the phrase I
am a sweet baby let's have fun together
this baby looks like a lot of things but
sweet is not the first thing that comes
to mind this baby looks like he might
steal your car robbed your house and run
a local money-laundering ring out of the
basement but he's definitely falling
short in the sweet and fun Department
this baby looks like he just got out of
the slammer and is trying desperately to
convince the parole board that he is a
changed infant this is the last thing a
kid would see before he got his lunch
money and his trike stolen a more
accurate phrase where the box would be I
am a crime boss let's do a jewel heist
together we've never felt so compelled
to call a baby a big fat liar before and
what parent would give this terrifying
thing to a kid this would be the
punishment doll tell Timmy he'd better
behave or he's gonna get two minutes in
the closet with the Eastern European
thug baby this baby looks like it ate
Daniel Craig right after he said I'm a
sweet baby let's have fun together ghost
story Mini Mouse when a child is afraid
of the dark many parents try to help her
get over her fears by giving her a
nightlight that seems like a good idea
until you see something like this this
Minnie Mouse nightlight is adorable it
seems sweet and innocent enough that is
during the day at night it's a pretty
dramatic difference when the lights go
out
Minnie goes from a sweet and playful to
dark and sinister
she seems like she would actually enjoy
it if a child would wet the bed and
terror does this nightlight softly play
heavy metal - maybe something like the
song let the bodies hit the floor or
inter Sandman this nightlight is
hilariously terrifying
it looks like Minnie has a frightening
ghost story and she is shining a
flashlight on her face for that earring
nightmarish effect what did she do to
Mickey
someone better send out a search and
rescue because it looks like Minnie is
into some dark stuff after the Sun Goes
Down this nightlight will definitely
help a kid get over his fear of the dark
because after seeing this he would
happily take Lane in the dark over
staring at the shadows of those ears and
that creepy smile
we need the poon with dentures when we
see this rendition of the sweet honey
loving bear from the Hundred Acre Wood
we have a few questions why why why is
this terrifying stuffed bear meant to be
a cautionary warning to children about
what will happen if you Gorge out on
honey everyday and don't brush your
teeth
did the toy makers still these dentures
from an old man we are imagining the
thought process that resulted in this
ridiculous frightening finished product
what's he thinking ah forget the nose
noses are overrated you know what would
make this toy better man-sized choppers
if they don't fit pull out a horse snout
there now it's got a horse fair face
with no nose perfection can you imagine
the horrified look on a kid's face at
seeing this monstrosity for the first
time be careful kid if you misbehave
this bears gonna bite your face off
we're not even sure Winnie the Pooh has
teeth he has a sweet squishy
honey-glazed smile that looks nothing
like this creepy stuffed toy it looks
like this bear and a set of toy toppers
and can't spit them out we hope the kid
who got this bear wasn't scarred for
life
star wars airs this one has so many
hilarious things going on we don't even
know where to start but we're going to
take a crack on it this is an obvious
example of a toy manufacturer in a
different country who has no idea what
the Star Wars franchise is trying to
capitalize on merchandise without
getting sued for trademark violations it
seems like they were a bit off on the
translations or they decided they could
come up with something better than
George Lucas did at the top at Reed's
galaxies are far far away lol then it
changed the name to Star Wars and
apparently in this galaxy Ralph Macchio
is working as karate farmer and you
eight Samuel Jackson he's going to need
to be pretty tough to defeat door ladder
don't you think Yoda isn't even called
Yoda on the package
he has been downgraded to just wise
puppet so in this version of Star Wars
the wise
Sam Jackson puppet teaches Ralph Macchio
to grow potatoes and then karate chop
them into fries so he can be strong
enough to fight door ladder and resist
going to the dark slide it's your
standard epic tale of gourd vs. stevia
Harry baby you can shave so what you've
learned from this picture of a hairy
ginger baby is that we know nothing of
the world apparently there the country
out there we're bored children begged
their parents to buy them a doll with
Sasquatch hair growing out of its calves
and a serious case of aggressive puberty
why you might ask so they can shave it
makes perfect sense this doll looks like
it ate a muppet that didn't agree with
him and didn't make it to the bathroom
on time and what's with the odd hair
wings on the back of its shoulders there
is a place on this earth where babies
look like this we never want to go there
why would any kid be obsessed with
shaving red hair off of a baby body and
who has given these kids razors this is
the stuff nightmares are made up
seriously
you can't unsee this someone out there
thought they would finally get to the
bottom of the hairy ginger baby doll
shortage that was plaguing a nation of
sad disappointed children quick tip if a
baby has bushy armpit hair the first
step isn't to shave it you better get
that kid to the science lab so doctors
can study it
yikes and that's it pretend mess of toys
no kid would want as a present thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]